we got we went to the you comfortable is
it the city Paul
good morning everybody
I'm Kimberly Gulf cruise I'm secretary
and vice president for student life here
at Yale and it is my pleasure my true
pleasure to welcome all of you in the
audience and those of you live streaming
on behalf of the University to this
session of the Kerry initiatives Yale
climate conference yells has had a
long-term commitment to a sustainable
environmentally responsive campus and so
it is fitting that secretary Kerry's
first major event at Yale focuses on
environmental responsibility and action
yells commitment was strengthened
recently as president Peter salivate
together with eleven other university
presidents founded a coalition to
address the rise in global temperatures
and to help create a clean energy
economy in July the university also
implemented a carbon charge this
groundbreaking initiative the first for
any US University will tax University
buildings for the cost of their carbon
emissions we will research and develop
learning that we hope will influence
national carbon pricing policy we're
very excited our goal is to reduce
campus greenhouse emissions 43 percent
below our 2005 levels by 2020 this
morning secretary Kerry a member of the
Yale College class of 1966 we're proud
to say will moderate a discussion on
state city and international efforts
toward responsible action regarding
climate change we are fortunate that he
is joined by four panelists who have set
an example of environmental leadership
and courage Governor Jerry Brown of the
state of California also Yale Law School
class of 1964 and governor jay Inslee of
the state of Washington have pledged to
continue to work on climate change
following the United States withdrawal
from the in Paris climate change
agreement both have spent much of their
life advocating for the environment and
for citizen engagement and legislative
action that leads to greenhouse gas
reduction and energy innovation we are
also joined by Anne Hidalgo mayor of the
city of Paris who co-hosted the climate
summit for local leaders in 2015 and was
released recently elected as the chair
of C 40 cities a network of 90 cities
committed to climate change that
together constitute over 650 million
people 650 million people and one
quarter of the world economy and finally
we're joined by Jim Yong Kim president
of the World Bank was also the former
president of our sister institution
Dartmouth College he is called the Paris
agreement a defining moment in human
history and has identified climate
change as a key issue that must be
addressed in the fight to reduce global
poverty secretary Kerry as I turned the
program over to you I'd like to say on
behalf of the institution how happy we
are that the initiative is here at the
Jackson Institute and to welcome you
back home to Yale thank you
thank you very much
Kim thank you very very much thank you
to all of you for getting up and it's
not that early we are really pleased to
be able to welcome you here this morning
and I hope the sound works out and you
can hear us I know there's a little bit
of an echo but this is such a beautiful
hall and we knew we were going to have
more people than any of the other
facilities would allow so we took a
chance and thank you all for for being
here
first of all Kempton thank you very much
the university is deeply involved in
working on climate change and there's an
effort that has been worked on for some
period of time here which is the carbon
charge that you may have read about in
the daily today but the university is
now implementing a campus-wide carbon
fee system so that each of the buildings
some 250 buildings will be responsible
for their own carbon footprint this has
been worked on for some period of time
being announced today and I congratulate
the university on doing that it will
involve something like 70% of all the
carbon emissions of the University and
Yale is the first University in the
United States to do this so
congratulations to everybody who's had a
part of that this panel let me just say
with respect to the last yesterday and
today yesterday morning we had a
terrific panel involving the former
Secretary of Energy Ernie Moniz our
climate envoi Jonathan Pershing and
others who talked about where we are on
energy and the importance of energy
policy the transition that can take
place and must take place in order to
deal with the challenge of climate
change there is a solution to climate
change it's not something we have to
wait for in the future it's here now
it's called energy policy and if we were
to implement the right choices with
respect to wind and biomass and
solar and so forth which our panelists
will talk about there's an enormous
amount that we can do and and move much
faster so we also had Jeff ml and former
Secretary of Treasury Hank Paulson who
talked about the private sector role in
all of this and you're going to hear
about all of this again today because
this panel represents real stuff that is
happening real decision-making by
governors by mayor by the head of the
World Bank and the World Bank has
enormous leverage and its ability to be
able to create change on a global basis
now this afternoon we will have former
Secretary of State Jim Baker he happens
to also be former almost everything else
he's the three-time presidential
campaign manager he was the Secretary of
Treasury he was chief of staff in the
White House there's really amazingly
knowledgeable person who at age 88 is
still active and moving he's going to be
here this afternoon to talk about carbon
carbon pricing and the political playing
field on a bipartisan basis and we will
also hear from Senator John McCain
Senator Lindsey Graham by video they
couldn't be here because of the bill on
the floor but they're going to speak and
that's welcoming people back to this
fight who need to be part of it and then
finally Leonardo DiCaprio will be with
us this afternoon at five o'clock here
in this hall to talk about citizen
activism which Jerry knows full well as
I do and I think Janos is at the heart
of how we're going to save ourselves
from ourselves so that's the lineup but
right now we have with us four
extraordinary leaders on this and public
servants who are making key decisions
about public policy regarding this and I
think we're gonna have a fun I hope
engaging back and forth conversation
more than any speeches at you and I'll
have a chance to ask a few questions to
try to elicit some what we want to try
to get at so let's just sort of dig in
if we can
I'm going to begin with governor Inslee
who has a cap-and-trade program in the
state of Washington Jay has been a
member of Congress a leader on this and
a community activist going way way back
it's how he first got involved and I'm
really delighted to welcome him here to
Yale so Jay if you'd share a few
thoughts just to open up and then we'll
come back and get into the dialogue well
thank you and thank secretary Kerry for
all your leadership this initiative is
very important I appreciate the
introduction I appreciate everybody
being here I wanted to think about a
comment I wanted to honor former Senator
Kerry with one of his predecessors of a
quote of John F Kennedy is inaugural
address I was thinking what fit this
context and of course we recall when
when he said that the torch has been
passed to a new generation tempered in a
harsh and bitter peace unwilling to
accept permit or witness the slow
erosion of the civil rights and human
dignity that America had stood for and I
think the same can be said for this
moment that the torch is being passed to
a new generation that has been tempered
by the harsh and bitter science the
demands we all act in unwilling to
witness or permit the slow erosion of
the atmosphere that sustains human
civilization and all we hold dear and I
think there's no more perfect place to
talk about passing that torch then here
at Yale to a generation that truly does
understand this science and truly does
demand its leaders act but that torch
has also been passed from the White
House where we would like to have the
torch of leadership on this measure two
other leaders two governors two mayors
two individuals two college students and
I think the fundamental message I would
have is that we all need to Pat pick up
that torch that has been dropped for
the current occupant of the White House
and hold it tie and high and bright as
high as we can and that's what it is
necessary at the moment that good news
is we're picking up that torch the
governor's a Governor Brown governor
Coleman on herself within 36 hours of
the president running up the white flag
of surrender to the forces of climate
change when he bailed on the Paris
agreement within 36 hours we had stood
up a new organization called the United
States Climate Alliance and it's
appropriately called the United States
Climate Alliance because states are
powerful in this regard and we now have
14 states in this alliance who have both
pledged and shown teeth and meat on the
bone of policies to decarbonize our
economy and that's succeeding and that's
the good news
our alliance represents 40 percent of
the United States economy and we can
legitimately tell presidents prime
ministers mayor's around the world the
United States is not bailing on this
effort the United States is acting with
the United States Climate Alliance and
that's alive and well and that's what
the governor browner and I are here to
talk about just briefly I'll tell you
the things that we're doing in my state
I have imposed a cap Washingtonians
deserve a cap limiting the amount of
carbon pollution that is damaging my
state this morning there is a thousand
firefighters trying to prevent a fire
from burning down the city of Roslyn
Washington it is a beautiful place I'm
here to say I'm not going to allow that
without a fight and our fight starts
with a cap on carbon pollution and I
have placed that it's the first
executive order in the United States
that caps the amount through a
regulatory concrete enforceable lawful
means to guarantee Washingtonians they
won't be strangled by carbon dioxide we
have a clean energy fund which has
developed a company that has the largest
vanadium flow grid scale battery in the
world today we're moving a help is on
the way thanks for holding up that torch
Thank You secretary
J thank you very very much and thank you
for the outstanding job that you were
doing I just comment everybody here that
this alliance and the efforts that exist
out there there's a live by Paris effort
there's that we're still in effort and
the Alliance is bringing everybody
together in order to send the message as
strongly as possible the message is this
the president United States may have
decided to pull out of Paris but the
people of the United States remain
committed to Paris and we are not only
going to meet the Paris agreement in my
judgment we are going to exceed it and
the reason we're going to do it is
because of what Governor Inslee and
Governor Brown and other governors
around the country doing 29 states in
the United States have passed a
renewable portfolio standard that
represents 70% of the population of the
nation another eight states are pursuing
a voluntary personable portfolio
standard so together those 38 states
represent 80% of the population of the
United States and we are already more
than 50% of the way to meeting our Paris
support the problem is and jury noses
third anybody in Paris we didn't set we
could because we couldn't create a
mandatory mechanism for a lot of reasons
so what Paris did was send a message to
the marketplace you got to start
investing and changing and what's
happened since Paris is we have doubled
the amount of money that is now being
invested in alternative renewable energy
over the amount that's going into fossil
fuel and for the first time in American
history more money is going into
alternative renewable energy than fossil
so that's the product of the work of
these governors and the mayors on the
grassroots level there is an
organization called c40 which is an
organization of the cities around the
world
and Hidalgo the mayor of Paris is
chairing that now and she's going to
chat with us a little bit about what
cities can do and how important it is
for cities to be able to take the lead
here Andy thank you so much for being
here with us thank you so much thank you
thank you John
for their this invitation I'm very happy
very proud
a little afraid because you have to
support my very very French accent and
I'm sorry but but I'm happy to be here
with all these big leaders and thank you
for your leadership Joan of course today
cities are the right level with States
to act and to fight against climate
change
we are the right level because we are a
level a democratic level at a human
level and in the cities we can have and
build strategies we can build aliens
with private sector with citizens with
NGOs and also with all the people who
knows that we have to do now not
tomorrow now it is an urgency to act
today and today when you see all the
cities the global cities in the world
the mayor the community of the mayor of
global cities we share the same visions
we are very committed together in this
fight because we see we are on the
forefront of all the global issues in
our cities we are the cities who produce
the gas emissions and we are also the
cities who the problem Kim
and we have to act very very quickly
today all the cities are very close in
this vision and we we organize Network
the c40 the c40 is a network with none
know 40 cities but 91 cities we will
change the name because 40 was in the
past
we are 91 cities bigger cities in the
world and we are committed engaged to
fight climate change and we represent
six under 50 million people in the world
we represent 25% of the GPD of the world
and we are powerful I think together in
the this right level to fight against
climate change
we can organize these aliens and be
efficient and be efficient today not
tomorrow about climate change because
climate change is terrific for the
humankind but with the climate change we
can have new opportunities in business
market in employment and also in
democratic managing of our communities
and together with the c40 we we are very
committed we work with UN with
international organization because today
maybe cities we are more agile we are we
have more agility than States
national states and this is why I think
the right level is here in a city like
Paris we share experience and I can put
in my policies in in Paris all the very
great experience that you in your States
in California in another city you have
and it's very interesting for us because
we don't have time to to to wait and
when we share the experience we can go
faster and quickly well today I think in
the world our network with NGOs and
international institution we can have
this powerful aliens and when we heard
the President of the United States when
you talk about Paris agreement and we
don't understand what he said and and we
don't know what happens today because
speaking UN but we are a majority in the
planet who we think that we need to act
today and together
and we are very powerful we are very
powerful more than the President of the
United States I'm sorry
I prefer to say to you
and in our network we have a lot of city
of American cities of America are with
us in California but also New Orleans
Chicago New York San Francisco the
cities are together in this fact and we
act and I think our our powerful is to
be a vice generic and to be very
concretely and we are together in this
fight we need your help
also because yes we have this problem
now with the President of the United
States but we have also problem many
times with the [ __ ] news the fake news
need to be fight and we need also
journalists we need also media's because
it's not possible to fight and to hurt
that know climate change it's it's just
an adult ideology no it's not an
ideology it's really it's a reality and
we need also with private sector with
citizen with NGOs with international
level with city states have with us
journalists because the fake news is for
us today very dangerous very dangerous
and we we have to be stronger together
and thanks if the journalists came with
us in this fight Thank You Annie thank
you very very much
I know that
Ann was concerned about delivering all
those comments in English but I think
you were she didn't miss a word and she
did it with a beautiful accent nothing
Jim Kim one of my delights serving his
Secretary of State and before that in
the Senate was working with Jim and I
have to tell you he has taken the world
bank into modernity and particularly
refocused it in its financing approach
and it's thinking about how to stimulate
investment in the right areas and has
been central to our ability to get a
Paris agreement done a lot of other
things so Jim thank you for your
tremendous work and thanks for being
here today you you were my senator and
so as always I go wherever you ask me to
I have to say you know they told me that
this place seats 2,500 people and they
told me it would be full and I said are
you kidding me college students ten
o'clock in the morning but you guys have
done great but we didn't get quite 2500
this is the former president of
Dartmouth speaking Dartmouth we would
never get this number number of people
you know let me talk a little bit about
what's happening in the world right and
so it's kind of crazy for me to think
that in this country in very close to
where I work every day in Washington DC
there's a debate about climate change
because there's not a single African
head of state who has not convinced that
climate change is real the famine that
we're facing now 20 million people
potentially at risk of a famine this is
directly related in the minds of the
heads of state of Africa to climate
change what they say is that you and the
rich world debate climate change we in
Africa have the boot of climate change
on our necks now it's not just that
there are heavy rain
it's not just that there are droughts
but most of the infrastructure in in in
Africa for example is not climate
resilient so what roads washed-out
bridge bridges wash out the countries
are completely debilitated when these
things happen and you know I I asked the
director of science in the White House a
year and a half ago well what is this he
says you know it's actually pretty
simple if the air is warmer and the
oceans are warmer the storms are going
to be worse now look everyone has to be
careful about tying any particular event
to climate change but I'm telling you in
most of the developing world the
awareness of this is intense now here's
here's the issue in my mind you know
lots of good things are happening
I think the Paris agreement was great
but I I worried because the next step
after the Paris agreement was putting
the deals together that would transform
our ability to invest in both mitigation
and adaptation now I think that we
suffered from a sort of collective
hangover we celebrated so much after
Paris that the next step which is to say
so where are the deals
how can we invest more it took almost a
full year to get that conversation
started again
secretary Kerry is right that that now
it's increasing but a doubling of
investments is nowhere close to what we
need we need many many trillions of
dollars so just to give you a couple of
quick numbers in cities just in cities
over the next 15 years over excuse me in
the entire world
there will be 90 trillion dollars
investment in infrastructure and that 90
trillion dollars represents more
infrastructure investment than in the
entire history of the world prior to
that in the next 15 years and 70% of
that will be in cities and the question
is will there be enough financing to
make sure that that infrastructure
investment is climate smart will be will
we be using
bus rapid transit will we be using
electric cars will we increase the
density of cities to reduce the carbon
footprint and right now the answer has
to be not yet because the financing is
not available you know over 60% of the
world cities will be at risk for
tsunamis and storm surges flood losses
were about six billion dollars in 2005
by 2050 it'll be 50 more than 50 billion
dollars a year so what do you do and
give me if you indulge me for just a
second twenty twenty some years ago I
was part of a movement and the movement
was called 50 years is enough and in
that movement we called for the closing
of the World Bank in the International
Monetary Fund on the occasion of its
50th birthday in 1994 so I was on the
streets protesting against the World
Bank in 1994 and now I'm president go
figure
you know I in fact told President Obama
when he interviewed me to nominate me I
told him that III have to say I'm
incredibly grateful and maybe he was one
of the few presidents who would have
actually nominated me but now that I
have gotten into the World Bank Group
there's a very specific message that I
want to send to all of you you know one
of my heroes is a professor right here I
don't know if he's here
professor Robert Shiller in the
Economics Department and professor
Shiller wrote this incredible book that
that he later told me hasn't sold very
well but he wrote this incredible book
called finance in the good Society
and he wrote the book as a is almost a
love letter to his students who were
part of the Occupy movement and he tried
to make the case that many many good
things in the world can happen if you
get the financing right let me just give
you some examples so in India
Prime Minister Modi has a huge ambition
huge ambition to to move away from coal
and to solar energy but the problem
right now is the cost of capital
financing is a major issue and it's a
question of whether we can find the
financing
that will keep up with Prime Minister
Modi's and ambitions in other countries
the major emitters Indonesia Vietnam
Pakistan Philippines in those countries
we find that that the leaders want to
move toward cleaner solutions but the
financing is not available so there is a
fantastic opportunity right now over 10
trillion dollars is sitting in negative
interest rate bonds that means that if
you go to the Japanese central bank or
the European Central Bank or the German
central bank you give them your money
instead of what normal banks do pay you
interest you actually pay them to hold
your money so over 10 trillion dollars
negative interest rate bonds another 20
trillion or so sitting in government
bonds earning very little usually less
than 1% interest and another 8 trillion
dollars or so sitting in people safes
with you know thousand euro bills just
sitting in cash because there's so much
uncertainty now of that 40 trillion
dollars or so everyone is looking for
higher return the the Indians the
Indonesians the Pakistanis the great
emitters who are who want to move in a
direction of low-carbon energy provision
don't have access to capital to make
those investments so what we're trying
to do is use every single tool we have
and this is dead-- instruments where we
take first loss that reduces the risk
for the others who are investing we're
we have political risk insurance we have
credit enhancement that will will be
used when countries say okay we promise
to a private sector provider of solar
for example that we will make the
payments you know every month every year
or whatever but sometimes they get in
trouble so we can step in and provide a
kind of insurance and we'll make those
payments but the point I want to make
here is that this is really you know the
problem of climate change I think we
understand the science I think I think
there's a lot of great motivation but
the nationally determined contributions
that came out of Paris will not keep us
under two degrees Celsius it will not
keep us under two degrees Celsius
the key right now is to move on finance
and so we at the World Bank Group went
from in 2009 at the Copenhagen meetings
we were not allowed into the room
because we were the bad guys on the
climate change issue this year not only
were we in the room but we pledged to
get to 30 billion dollars a year by 2020
and we're on our way we're gonna get
there we're gonna be the largest funders
of climate change activity in the world
but it's still not enough
you know I end my I've ended a lot of my
talks on climate change
with with a pretty simple idea and
simple idea is that I have a 17 year old
son in an 8 year old son and based on
the way they already talked to me today
they're gonna say to me someday dad you
were president of the World Bank Group
why the hell didn't you do more why
didn't you do more you knew what the
issue was why didn't you do more now the
downside of that is that my
eight-year-old saw that on video is like
every other day or so he said dad do
more on climate change but the issue is
this folks the issue is this go read
professor Schiller's book write right
now
the block the blockage is access to
finance right now the the problem is is
making sure that all of the great
motivations and all the great
declarations that have been put on the
table can be taken forward this is the
hard work of actually making deals
happen secretary Kerry joined us last
April and we formed something called
invest for climate we're bringing
together investors we're bringing
together climate change specialists
leaders of countries we're bringing
together all the multilateral
Development Bank's the Asian Development
Bank inter-american Development Bank and
we're all coming together and saying
okay so can we offload risk here to you
know the local pension fund and then
bring in funders here and can we use
political risk insurance this is what we
have to do and it's not as glamorous as
talking about you know what the future
will look like
but it's what has to be done we are
committed to it and and and will
continue to push in that direction Jim
you
[Music]
thank you very much Jim and just to
underscore this investment opportunity
in direct contradiction to what
President Trump said when he said he's
putting America first by pulling us out
of Paris in effect he's putting us last
because he has lost the momentum he's
lost the credibility he's taken us out
of a process where all this future
marketplace is there and he's actually
put a cloud over American business and
you hear this in various parts of the
world and is nodding where our
businesses will suffer as a result of
the decision the president made because
people don't believe we're serious and
are offering leadership on this this
this this energy marketplace is the
largest market the world has ever seen I
mean you have about four to five billion
users today and it's going to go up to
nine billion users the next 20-30 years
and people buy energy they buy water
they buy transportation
so it's revenue producing which means
you can never return on investment and
yet we're not moving aggressively into
that marketplace Governor Brown I just
want to insert personally as somebody
that I have known and worked with and
followed for many many years now and he
has really set an example in the state
of California state of California
freestanding is probably the sixth
largest economy in the world and when
California decides to do something it
has an impact on the rest of the country
and the rest of the world to wit when
California sets automobile standards the
automobile industry has to listen and
move because they can't sell cars
anywhere else I mean they were not going
to be if they can't sell them in
California it's just not a genuine
marketplace so that's the impact
California has this man ran for governor
and had a profound impact on our
politics in the 1970s he was 1974 and 78
elected governor twice in California
he's been mayor of Oakland
a lot of people scratch their heads and
said what's that all about he proved he
could run a city and make things happen
they always been two more times the
governor of the state of California and
he has made California I assure you a
model for how to approach what governors
and states can do to make a difference
on this so I hope you'll join me in
welcoming the good governor of the state
of California Jerry Brown
thank you and I do want to say we got we
are making progress I can tell you that
I was in Rio and 90 in 1992 when the
framework on climate change was adopted
and then nothing much happened I went
down to Johannesburg in 2002 and I saw
the Iranian ambassador talking to the
American ambassador all talking about
fossil fuel and rejecting many
resolutions at that point to encourage
renewable energy so not much happened
there now we get to Paris that was a
real commitment and as far from the
ultimate solution as it is it's a long
way from where we were just a few years
before so so that's good we are moving
in a positive direction and climate
change is at least talked about it was
only a couple of years ago when the
press barely would mention climate
change and I know that because I had
several press conferences with
scientists announcing relatively
relevant and important achievements or
ideas and there is zero press because
the idea of the end of the world is not
news
it really isn't news the latest little
news of the day predominates but now
with the Paris agreement that's been
changed you can actually find a lot of
stories on climate change and we're here
that shows you that we're making some
progress
but we still have a long way to go we've
got a lot of barriers so I want to talk
a little bit about that because money is
a problem because we're not spending it
but we just learned we have 40 trillion
sitting around doing nothing negative
low interest - so we can deploy that
that's just waiting now why can't we
deploy it because of politics and what
are the politics we have a bunch of
troglodytes in too many high places
now you know what a troglodyte is it's a
dweller in deep dark caves that is a
metaphor for the level of enlightenment
of those in charge of our political
structure in Washington today so that's
the threat it's a political threat now
we have we start with Trump but we have
his EPA director the former attorney
general of Oklahoma and he's just doing
everything he can to destroy and
dismantle the modest steps that were
made under President Obama so he's going
full-speed in the absolute wrong
direction so then we have that fellow of
Oklahoma the senator he's in charge of
the Environmental Committee mr. Inhofe
and this is their level his level he got
himself a snowball somehow and watch
this look this is a snowball there's no
global warming it's all a hoax and he
got that idea hoax and then that's what
Trump picked up the idea that climate
change is a hoax he didn't invent that
that was invented by other characters in
his general political constituency but
he added one little note to it he called
not only a hoax but it was a Chinese
hoax surely have the president actually
asserting and when the president asserts
something generally that's pretty
serious that all climate science all the
academies of science Russia England
France Germany America Japan Russia all
of them of all concluded and put out
papers about the seriousness of climate
change and it's human causation all
that's a hoax and it's a Chinese hoax so
that's about as preposterous and as
outrageous as you could get but we have
it and that didn't come just because
Trump thought it up one day there are
actual
companies corporations that are
promoting this propaganda and there are
institutes there is the Heartland
Institute I'll name oh there's the Cato
Institute there are other respectable
foundations that are all spewing torille
fabrications about one of the most
important issues of our day and those
are being picked up and then
disseminated right out of the White
House so that's that's what we're up
against and we're up against a governing
party the other party that I'm not a
member of whose name you all know but I
don't want to sound partisan so I'm not
going to mention it other than almost to
a person they deny human-caused climate
change you find me
well now maybe you're gonna get Lindsey
Graham and McCain hallelujah but good
that that's they haven't been saying
much last couple years they've been
pretty quiet in fact a lot of
Republicans talked about climate change
several years ago and they all shut up
something happened I guess they had a
meeting at the Koch brothers retreat or
something and they were all said shut up
don't talk about climate change and
almost it never happens well maybe today
you were gonna break through that and in
California we had eight Republicans and
our California Legislature that vote
voted for the most far-reaching
cap-and-trade bill in the country and we
got it because we needed two-thirds
votes and we needed Republicans and we
got them so there is a change there is a
turn that that's being made and that's
all to the good but we still have these
barriers where complete fabrications are
being promoted at government expense
through the office of the Environmental
Protection Agency and through the White
House itself so you in this intellectual
environment have their work cut out have
your work cut out for you we have to
first destroy the mythology that is
based on nothing because we have the
science we have a growing number of
chief executives
growing number of people all over the
world you've heard your other people
talk about it and yet we are prisoners
of this situation in Washington so
that's where we can work you may not be
able to get the world bank to do
something but you can through elections
through writing through encouragement we
can shift the political center of
gravity which right now is really tilted
now there are solutions and we're
finding them some of them in California
our cap and trade is significant because
we have a limit on greenhouse gas
emissions within the state and we have
the significant enterprises reporting
and we have third-party validators who
check on the reports so we know what the
emissions are and we know they're in the
approximate total of 440 million tons
per year of greenhouse gases and we have
a cap of 260 million by 2030 and each
year this cap from where we are today
is going down and that has now been
embraced in California by the farm
Bureau by the Chamber of Commerce by the
Business Roundtable and by significant
industries plus that most of the
Democrats and key Republicans so this is
an operational legal framework that is
that is now working in that state and we
could do that in other states and as we
get a little more enlightenment along
the election front we can explain
tomorrow more States so there is a
solution
we also are we have auctions under this
cap and trade just last month we had an
auction
collected over a billion dollars of
companies buying allowances because they
couldn't meet the cap and every year
those allowances will get more expensive
as it comes down so we're
and by the way with that billion dollars
we spend money we're paying people to
buy an electric car
we're para spending tens of millions of
dollars on dairies to get bio digesters
that reduce methane emissions I mean we
are very specific with real money with
real law enforced by the authorities in
California so we know it can be done but
we got to pick it up
and we need out of the states and yes
while we're waiting for the president to
come back into reality there's a lot we
can do and there's a lot that
universities can do and that nonprofits
and think tanks I mean this is a battle
for survival and you know it's not like
the world is going to fall off in next
month but the unique issue of climate
change is that we're not quite sure of
where we stand and there's something
called tipping points and things can tip
over setting the world on an
irreversible trajectory of not to prison
two degrees centigrade above the
industrial period three four and on and
on there's a 5% chance that sea level
will rise eight feet by the end of this
century
I mean think of New York and Miami and
New Orleans not to mention Shanghai and
Bangladesh and all these other places so
it's a real mortal threat it's a threat
to the entire world but it's not today
it's not tomorrow although actually if
we pass the tipping point that we don't
understand we might be there before we
know it so we have to mobilize to take
out this threat and the threat is real
and when the threat is your own
president that becomes complicated you
know what else can you do but I liked
another president I'd again think of it
any other way and that's real simple
except to get more votes in the
electoral college they need it so that's
what you got to do and it is politics
and it's science and its intellectual
investigation and it's this financing it
solve it together
the knowledge is here the solutions at
hand all you have to do is get it done
and I will join with you and we will see
it over the next couple of years we will
drive the hoax hucksters out of
Washington and bring in some common
sense truth about where we stand and
where we gotta go
[Applause]
it's good to have somebody who is clear
[Laughter]
no minced words so we've just had a
storm Harvey that dumped more water more
rainfall than ever before historic
record broken
we've just had a storm Irma which is the
first hurricane to ever have sustained
winds over 185 miles an hour for entire
24 hours and we have record wildfires
burning up in the state of California
and state of Washington elsewhere three
immutable facts they're happening and
yet as Jerry just described we have
leaders so-called who ignore these facts
and Hidalgo raised the issue of fake
news and I wanted just assets we have
two currently elected officials on the
dais with us and then I'd like to get
Jim involved in this too so how is it
that apart from the money apart from the
special interest part of it that's
driven by a Cato Institute or by the
Koch brothers or so forth which we all
acknowledge that's always been a part of
our politics but what is different today
appears to be the inability of anybody
to settle on facts I mean John Adams
once said facts are stubborn things Pat
Moynihan my colleague in the Senate said
everybody's entitled to their own
opinion but are not entitled to your own
facts yet this is an administration that
is presented alternative facts so how do
we break through what has happened that
the dialogue of our democracy is
actually capable of settling on facts
and I will tell you from a governing
point of view it is really hard to build
consensus if you can't begin to decide
what the truth is so Jerry wait would
you pick up on that for a minute and
want to come over to UJ and see how we
push back against this because it is
stealing our democracy and it is
stealing the future because it prevents
us from being able to make these
rational common-sense decisions based on
empirical evidence what is one of the
barriers of course is the media habit of
presenting fair and balanced news to use
the phrase and they balance it so if if
somebody says two plus two is four and
somebody else says two plus two is five
they have to give a little bit of equal
time to the absurdity now that's an
extreme case but in the case of climate
change that's kind of what it is I think
the key is winning over more business
leaders there are a number of business
leaders already there are even oil
companies energy companies there are a
lot of businesses and their CEOs that
are joining in the effort to decarbonize
the economy now they are a very powerful
pillar of the Republican Party and the
key here is you've got to change many
Democrats but you have to crack the
republican party much further open than
it is to the climate science so I think
that is where the focal point has to be
getting the business community through
specific corporations to join in the
effort and they're already in various
alliances and part of what we're doing
is not only states and cities but it's
disciplines what is your goal and how
far how close are the electorate if you
look at the electorate itself you'll
find that there's a well over twenty to
thirty percent of Republicans who
believe in climate change so that's that
one might be my simple formula work with
the rule of the business people
transform those aspects of our political
parties that are the hindrance and then
move ahead with the financing and the
other regulatory and legal actions that
we all know we have to
and just to emphasize the yesterday Jeff
Immelt who is the outgoing CEO of
General Electric one of our largest
companies most successful companies said
very clearly that President Trump's
decision to pull out of Paris is a bad
for business decision and that it's
going to handicap American businesses
and businesses he said have to have
their own foreign policy that's a very
dramatic statement to come from a
fortune 500 company CEO and I think it's
indicative of what Joe is saying that
companies see that this landscape this
marketplace is changing dramatically
biggest market the world has ever seen
trillions of dollars are going to be
spent in it and if American business is
going to succeed American business gonna
have to be at the table Jay what about
on the whole issue of the news and and
your ability now to lead the democratic
process in a way that's rational well I
would say that we should spend less time
thinking about how to change the mind of
a climate denier who decides to ignore
settle science and settle on a focused
aggressive intense personally dedication
to remove them from office these people
need to be removed from office where
they cannot do harm you are never going
to convince a climate denier who brings
a snowball to the floor of the Senate
that we ought to do something about this
we simply have to focus on removing them
from office now most people think
extinction is a bad thing but it's a
good thing to make climate deniers
politically extinct and that is what
needs to happen in our body politic now
let me tell you why let me tell you I
bring this up Jerry had tremendous
success this year in California
maintaining the cap-and-trade system I
talked to one of the Republican leaders
of their legislature who voted for in
their eight or nine who voted for that
for the measure and I asked him why did
you do that and he said I'll just give
you a straight answer I've concluded the
Republican Party will be extinct if we
don't get on board doing something this
about this obvious problem
and the reason they can and should be
extinct not the whole party but at least
climate deniers is the people in this
room the people in this room understand
your future is dependent on solving this
problem and I want to make a personal
pitch to you to do something about this
problem now we got governors and World
Bank and mayors up here and former
secretaries of state but what we need or
Eli's knocking on doors and using your
social networks to elect people in state
legislatures that can affect state
policies and City Council members they
can elect City Council policies and
senators and presidents and we need that
right away and I gotta tell you I sat
where you were 45 years ago I was at the
University of Washington started to
study clean energy and I'm still at it
but there's something I want to say we
need to come true
when I was a freshman we used to have
freshmen movies if I don't say have
freshmen movies here but we we were
fresh movies every Sunday night one of
the first ones we saw was Casablanca I'd
never seen it before before I was a
freshman in college my favorite line in
that was when Humphrey Bogart said we'll
always have Paris I want to say we're
gonna always have Paris and we're always
going to have Paris we're going to have
Eli's knocking on doors to elect people
in the next election cycle and it is
imperative to do that I just want to ask
you to personally make a commitment that
the next time you hear Donald Trump say
something that's absolutely asinine when
it comes to climate change
the yo go find a candidate to support to
elect to these positions we need you
you're powerful and I'll tell you why
we're always going to have Paris when
I've looked at this Climate Alliance
that we have set up we have learned that
if you want to grow your economy grow
your climate change efforts you know
when we passed a renewable portfolio
standard several years ago the fossil
fuel industry said if you do that you'll
destroy your economy then when I passed
my executive order to put a cap on
carbon dioxide the fossil fuel industry
said you will destroy your economy
isn't it a great thing that CNBC just
listed the best place to do business in
the United States of America is the
state of Washington because we're
fighting climate change and we're
building clean energy jobs like crazy
that's why we're gonna win this but
there's a second reason I'll diss
finished on this way we're gonna win
this Donald Trump cannot stop us it
doesn't matter what he does he cannot
stop us this is an effort that is alive
in Seattle it's alive in Washington it's
alive in California it's alive in Des
Moines Iowa he cannot stop us he will
not stop us we will win this battle so
I'm gonna ask one more question of Jim
Kim on this broader subject then I want
to come back to the specifics of what
cities and states are doing a little bit
and then I want to ask you after Jim
about Paris's specific steps because I
think it's important for people to know
what's happening but Jim wearing not
just out of World Bank and all the
countries and leaders you interact with
on a daily basis but as a former
universe Brett just if you share your
thoughts about this difficulty of
building consensus governing today and
and the whole issue of settling on facts
in the context of our democracy today
let me start by saying that in the
articles of agreement of the World Bank
Group World Bank employees are forbidden
from getting involved in the internal
politics of any of their member
countries so let me start with that and
then offer offer some some thoughts on
this you know one of the things we've
learned is that no matter what happens
in an election anywhere in the world the
the science doesn't change and for an
organization like the World Bank Group
if we depart from the science we lose
our credibility very very quickly and so
I've made it clear to every single one
of our governors that we will we will
now and forever be an organization
focused on science and therefore we have
no choice but to go forward aggressively
with our efforts on climate change now
you know as a former university
president I have to say that over the
last couple of years on this issue of
climate change the universities have not
been very present in the discussion and
I know personally many fantastic climate
scientists and for some reason that
voice hasn't come through as clearly as
it could have and I would just say that
you know if there's if there is a way
to think about how the messages rather
than sitting back with with disdain for
the discourse as it exists but somehow
thinking about the way to bring the
research that's happening in places like
Yale and bringing it into the center of
the discourse you know this is really
important because I think some of the
you know it's not just that that that
there are certain political leaders all
over the world not only are they arguing
with the post 1945 World Order you know
the World Bank exists because in 1945
there was a sense that my goodness
currency wars and the destruction of
Europe these things we have to figure
out a way to stop and so the UN was
created the Bretton Woods institutions I
mean from the World Bank were created
other organizations like NATO and oacd
all these organizations were created so
that there would be a place that
countries could go to talk about facts
to talk about science and to talk about
a way forward that benefited everybody
and so in many ways it's worked it's
it's work we don't we haven't had more
wars and in Europe that's there's been
many things that have been positive
about it but not only do we see a
rejection of the post 1945 World Order
sometimes we see a rejection of the of
the of the post enlightenment World
Order and I think that this is something
that the universities have to take very
seriously
now we at the World Bank Group by
agreeing that we're not going to be
political we then have to say that our
commitment is to evidence and always
working on the basis of evidence we have
to work with all of our members the
United States is the largest shareholder
at the World Bank Group we continue to
work with them on things other than then
climate change like for example a a very
promising women's entrepreneurship
initiative we will continue to do that
but at the same time because we're
focused on the science we we won't veer
from the path that we've taken but we
really need your help we need the help
of academic institutions to
step up and get a little bit dirty you
know I and my experience with academic
institutions is that those arguments are
so below us that we're not going to
engage I think the stakes especially if
you think about the the people in the
developing countries who are just
getting battered even today in the
Caribbean getting battered by by climate
change that I don't think there's any
room for the kind of disdainful approach
that I unfortunately have experienced a
lot in many of the universities so today
more than half of the world's population
lives in cities and by 2030 not so far
away one in every three people will live
in a city that is about a half a million
people cities now ninety are incredible
incubators of initiatives Building Codes
you know realize this but buildings
provide a huge percentage of greenhouse
gas emissions the choices that are made
with respect to zoning requirements
recycling transportation public
transportation density I mean all of
these issues are available to us as the
tools to try to conglomerate what we
need to do to meet this challenge which
is gigantic and an Hidalgo in Paris
appropriately have taken some really
important initiatives and are continuing
to break new ground so and if you'd
share with us what Paris has done what
is your vision for how Paris is going to
continue to set an example here thank
you
just first I agree what you say of
course and we have to build consensus
with the business world
it's very important because our
credibility is with business world if we
can prove that yes we put we bring new
opportunities for our citizens for
employment and it's very important to
build that I have two example in in this
topic first in our agenda in Paris in
October we organized we will organize
meeting between CEOs of companies in
Swiss areas because this three areas are
very connected with city's
transportation mobility real estate
construction and energy and mayors and
CEOs together like divers but Davos with
cities and not in Davos in Paris and I
think this this meeting will be very
efficient for us because in these aliens
in this we need to convince people
journalists and the people who think are
sinking in the old world and we are here
we build the new world with the climate
change opportunity because it is also an
opportunity and with the first
revolution Industrial Revolution with
the digital revolution and we can do it
we can do it and convince and I think we
can win in this fight second we have in
Paris the birthday celebration of the
Paris agreement the 1212 this year and
the president Macker organised summits
as some it about finance because we need
today to bring the finance and this
finance have to help and to to help to
build these new opportunities for this
new world and we have to forget the old
world today in Paris we work a lot about
my first goal is to reduce air pollution
because is the first topic we have the
according to the World Health
Organization the air pollution kills 3
million peoples worldwide and in my city
each year 2015 people did because air
pollution and we have to fight that and
for that yes we built police's for the
reduce the traffic the car traffic and
also to help to have new mobilities with
car sharing with electric car with
bicycle and we have an invitation
together to make a budget about your
affairs with the mayor it's a project
and it's very very important but let me
please because we we talk a lot about
transportation construction and energy
but one idea for me ecology is not just
scientific issues of business issues is
also human issue is also social issue
I'm not the author of
these words is the pop the Pope Francois
when you say ecology isn't humanism and
we need to have this ID very present
when we build policies in our cities
because we have to build inclusive
cities if you have if we have ecological
policies but just for one piece of
citizens it's not great in our cities in
global cities we have three populations
one the winners of globalization people
like us we we have graduation we for us
the world is our world and in our cities
we have also loser of globalization
these people is in our global city
because in it protection and we need to
give this protection and with the
climate change with this fight we need
to work with these people to not just
with the winner and on the middle we
have the middle class who work for our
cities for economy for well we need this
middle class and our policies will be
very inclusive because if we work just
for one part of these people we can't
win it's impossible we need to to be
very inclusive in our policies and
that's why in Paris our policies in
adaptation about climate change in fact
about air pollution we put in these
policies a lot of social policies
because we need to be very inclusive and
to have not just consensus with leaders
business leaders and politicians and
journalists but also with all the
citizens and winners and loser too we
have to to bring policies for all these
people is if we will win in this fight
again climate change the secretary could
I the mayor provoked a thought we are so
appreciative we've had a president to
try to shut the door to refugees many
refugees or climate refugees we've heard
about that
Paris France the whole of Europe has
stepped up to the plate to help these
refugees we give a round of applause for
Europe and Paris
J thank you you're absolutely right and
it's been a very significant political
cost I might add Jerry at the federal
level when there was an attempt to try
to move cap and trade we ran into this
ideological wall ironically cap and
trade came out of the American
Enterprise Institute it was a
conservative idea originally because it
was market-based but then the ideologues
grabbed onto it and transformed it into
a better R that is unacceptable because
it's quote command and control
interference of government in the
marketplace now complete flip to talk
about the sophistry of our recent
politics so how did you in California I
know you have a legislature that's
that's of the same party so you've got
uniform ability to move forward but you
obviously ran into these arguments and I
wonder if you'd share with people how
you knock those down or overcame them in
order to institute a cap-and-trade
system in California itself well to
institute it actually that was done by
my predecessor Arnold but Schwarzenegger
had some big ideas high-speed rail
nonpartisan primaries so one of these
was greenhouse gas reduction and he
joined with essentially all the
Democrats I think he got maybe one
Republican vote and he put the first
cap-and-trade program into effect and
then it was to expire in 2020 and the
second round I was able to lead the
effort to get it extended to 2030 and we
did that in part with the help of the
Republican minority leadership who came
in to see me many months ago and said we
want to do something on climb
change also there was a certain amount
of resistance from the Democrats because
there is resistance and they were rather
reluctant so there was another factor
the year before I proposed a 50%
reduction in oil use in California a
very bold move and along with that the
cap on overall greenhouse gases well the
oil companies mobilized to stop the 50%
reduction in oil and they kind of lost
sight of the power of the cap once we
put the cap into place last year then
the companies had to say do we want to
be regulated by bureaucrats in the state
capital or do we want a market-based
system of auctions and allowances that
allows companies to either do what they
can do best or to pay some money to
other companies who found a more
efficient way to reduce overall
greenhouse gases so because we had the
cap we were able to then get all the
industries to support the cap and trade
because they knew it was about three
times cheaper and more efficient than a
regulatory approach of each individual
industry the cement industry refineries
and dairies all you know all the things
that are now would have to be regulated
are put under the cap-and-trade system
much more efficient impersonal it worked
it actually is quite elegant in the way
it works
one more point in the history of this
particular system which as I said I want
to emphasize there's nothing like it
anywhere else in America Quebec has one
and they're part of our system and
Ontario is going to join and they're
gonna be other states that will join but
not as yet now what was the first
challenge as soon as Arnold
Schwarzenegger put this into effect with
Democratic votes primary
we the oil companies to Cerro for one
Valero for another for a measure on the
ballot to repeal it and the people
mobilized investor named Tom Steyer and
mr. Schultz former Secretary of State
under Ronald Reagan they joined the
cause and a number of other people and
this particular popular referendum as we
call it initiative was defeated by 23
points so that was an incredible there
was a battle and we won the battle and
so it's step by step but it took a
Schwarzenegger to push it with the
Democrats then it took me to extend it
it took people to beat back the oil
companies and by this time around the
oil companies were actually in silent
support so the it takes battles the
first ones are harder it gets easier as
you go down the road and I just want to
end up by saying how important business
is we could not have gotten this if the
Chamber of Commerce and the round table
and the Farm Bureau and the Western
dairyman hadn't said we support it they
did say that so you got to get business
that's it and the Democrats and the
academics can only go so far but I think
the point I would make there was a
famous president General Motors named
Charles Wilson Charlie Wilson he said
what's good for General Motors is good
for America now we kind of ridicule that
in the 60s but nevertheless if General
Motors thinks climate action is good for
them then it will be good for America
because America will pick it up because
the the money plays a powerful interest
in our elections billions of dollars I
know I've raised 100 million dollars
myself it's not trivial who those people
are and the Republicans it's also plenty
important so that is kind of
it's pretty simple we know the threat we
know we need business allies we know the
universities and the nonprofit sector
can have a role in influencing all that
and we put it all together you can get
it done it is possible but the the hour
is late and we don't know how far down
the road to an irreversible climate
catastrophe we're headed so well that's
all I'm saying be a little optimistic
but be more activist to get it done and
you can't play a role because you folks
at Yale you all end up on all these big
corporations that's what are you going
whether you know it or not
and you're gonna be in corporate America
and don't forget what you heard today
and please implement it as soon as
possible thank you
J could you speak to the same thing
quickly just sort of share your
challenge now with the you've
promulgated cap-and-trade there's some
people rising in opposition to it
can you give us a sense of that road
ahead and well we have we've had a
different route so I have put it in we
have a cap a limit on the amount of
carbon dioxide that can be emitted in
state of Washington and that was imposed
by my executive order with my stroke of
the pen and pursuant to our state clean
air law so we have a binding cap that
limits the amount through a regulatory
system that regulates these industries
they have to reduce the amount of carbon
dioxide and I regular rate every year
required by our rule now won't surprise
you that the oil and gas industry is
challenging that it's a litigation but
we believe we are on firm ground to win
that a cap-and-trade system is elegant
because as Jerry said one thing I
learned Frank when I got my degree in
economics was that the market is
efficient and determining the cheapest
way to get these savings and it is an
elegance to us and that's why I fought
for it and helped Barack Obama and Nancy
Pelosi we passed a cap-and-trade system
through the US House of Representatives
we ran into the Republican Stonewall in
the Senate so there are multiple ways to
get to a cap but the cap is the
fundamental first thing you need now I
want to dovetail back about something I
talked about a little earlier businesses
are extremely important in the success
of these programs unfortunately in my
state I have many businesses that
support limitations on carbon high-tech
companies that understand that if
they're gonna have a virtual world to
sell software they need a real world
where people can breathe and don't die
of asthma and cancer and hurricanes and
fires so we have a lot of support for
these efforts in my state because they
understand it's economically productive
and by the way it's it's not a
coincidence it's not a coincidence that
the most rapidly growing economic on
amis in the states are the same states
that are taking action against carbon
pollution Washington California
New York these are the most rapidly
growing economies and guess what they
have in common they have actions against
carbon pollution because when you don't
waste energy you improve your
performance when you don't treat the
atmosphere as a sewer but rather is a
common asset that we all breathe in all
own you have better economic performance
this is not a surprise but Jerry
mentioned about how some of them some of
even silently there was support from
even the fossil fuel industry in his
cap-and-trade there is a reason for that
and the reason is the voters of
California elected members of his
legislature that were going to support
him in a regulatory approach if they
didn't do this cap and trade and that's
where you come in that's where you come
in because it doesn't matter how much
money the fossil fuel industry can put
in this lobbying effort if you are
successful in electing state legislators
across the country who will demand and
stand up for action and I'm saying you
got as much power as Donald Trump on
this right now and I'm serious about
that everybody in this room asthma as
much power I'll give you an example this
fall we have a special election state in
one state legislative race the winner of
that will determine control of the
Washington state legislature if one
candidate wins we will be able to move
forward on climate change legislation if
the other candidate wins we will not we
will be a dead stop the people of that
district and the people everywhere are
going to make that decision
I want to vest you in power as you walk
out of this room you're as powerful as
anybody else I hope you're gonna join
this cause thank you so
we're gonna wrap up we're gonna wrap up
in a couple of minutes to honor
everybody's schedules here including our
guests I just want to ask Jim Kim the
World Bank is this powerful institution
it has enormous leverage and ability to
make things happen Jim we talked about
this amount of money that's sitting on
the sidelines could you just share your
vision for where you see the bank being
able now to leverage risk de-risking
de-risking politically de-risking
financially and begin to move the
capital that we need which ultimately
may be one of the key plays in this
entire effort well first let me thank
governor Inslee Governor Brown and Mayor
Hidalgo because you know what they're
demonstrating is something really really
critical that we're seeing in other
parts of the world that you can decouple
economic growth from from carbon output
Germany has done that as a country and
there are many many other examples 33 US
states have been able to decouple
economic growth from carbon emissions
and so let me start by saying let me
give you some of the details of what
we're doing but I you know I didn't I
didn't mean to be too negative on the
disdainful part here's what I think we
really need from students and from from
communities like Yale there is as we've
heard an extremely inspiring a vision of
what the world would look like if
everyone was competing to find the
cleanest possible approach to providing
energy to building roads to building
cities and that's the kind of
competition we need to start the
cap-and-trade is so important for us
what what Governor Brown did what what
Governor Inslee has done this is so
important but we need a global system
now I think I think what we're going to
hear from Senator from secretary Baker
is that they're they're pushing this
idea that we need to think about a price
on carbon now if if there was a price on
carbon I think you'd see market
mechanisms kick in and people who are
not focused right now on trying to
build low-carbon solutions for the world
would go in thereat direction I think
that's really critical and this is the
great example we've seen here today but
here's what here's what we're doing so
it turns out that many investors look at
the entire developing world as just sort
of one big blob and so they will say
things to us like well we're really
worried about investments in Africa as
if Africa was a single country and so
we're now first of all trying to educate
people about the hugely different risks
from country to country and region
region in Africa and South Asia that's
that's one part but I think the other
thing that that we need to do is that
you know we have lots of capital we
borrow at the lowest rate of just about
anybody in the world for your finance
people on any given day I borrow it
about LIBOR minus ten basis points very
very low level almost as low as US
Treasury and so we can use our ability
to borrow at low cost we can use the
fact that we work with with donors from
all over the world and provide very low
cost capital to get things going
so let me just give you an example for
for the drop in the price of solar the
only thing that we have seen that rivals
the rapidity of the drop in the price of
solar is the the explosion of cell
phones and smart phones in the world
solar energy is on that path and the
demand is just huge and it's huge even
in Africa because we can do solar much
more quickly than coal or or or hydro or
even oil and gas and we can move it to
communities very very quickly now the
problem is again that investors or solar
providers who would who might go think
it's too risky so we do risk by actually
putting our own money on the table and
investing with them we do risk by taking
first loss on on dead instruments we do
risk by providing political risk
insurance credit enhancement a promise
to pay the the fees if the country can't
pay it at certain times but more more
importantly we will
we want to de-risk these investments in
a positive way we want the investors to
think well you mean I can earn a higher
return in fact a much higher return than
a negative interest rate and then also
have this amazing impact on making the
world cleaner a decarbonizing energy in
these countries and the answer is yes
but we haven't brought them all to the
table yet we're gonna start this process
literally tomorrow at the at the
Bloomberg forum we're gonna bring lots
of different folks together and every
time I've done it every time I've
brought the people together just like
Mary Hidalgo talked about every time
I've brought them together people have
been surprised at what the others are
capable of doing so my request to you is
help us and this is the sciences the
humanities you know architecture law
medicine you know help us envision this
inspiring sense of what the world could
look like and also I think you need to
point out that if the u.s. is not
involved in aggressively going after
these low-carbon technologies the US
will be left in the dust because other
countries are moving very aggressively
in that direction China Japan all over
East Asia in the European countries it's
it's it's an inspiring view but it's
also a dangerous one that if you keep
veering away from from these clean
technologies we'll be left in the dust
and an economic growth will will suffer
very very important point and eloquently
made and as we wrap up here let me just
share a couple of thoughts with all of
you if I can first of all I hope many of
you will be able to return all you can
return to here to in Baker and Leonardo
DiCaprio this afternoon and I will I'm
gonna say something to you now because I
don't know obviously who is able to be
back and I'm and I will share some of
this when we do the activism discussion
this afternoon but what you've heard
here is a brilliant example of why we're
a pretty powerful country and why we
have a beautiful idea in our democracy
and we're not alone in
there are other countries that share
that value but for people sitting here
who are steadfast and believing
something and fighting for it even if it
means standing up to powerful forces in
the country and they're making a
difference nothing is more important
than that right now the electricity the
the the potential of solar power is a
growth industry in America that is
growing 17 times faster per year than
our general economy the single fastest
growing job in America today which is
well-paying is a wind turbine technician
this notion that you have to choose
between the economy and doing something
about climate change is a creation of
these entities that don't want to change
anything and it's almost always a
creation of entities that are
ideologically standing in the way of
modernity and progress when I was in
Antarctica last year there was a New
Zealand scientist named Gavin Dunbar who
said to me you know what you're seeing
here in Antarctica is the canary in the
coal mine and he said some of the things
we're seeing here may be irreversible
it's the point Jerry made Jim I think
everybody here is making we don't know
what we don't know but as public people
we have a fundamental responsibility to
implement the precautionary principle we
buy insurance to protect our homes we
buy insurance not to have our car
uninsured if we have a crash so on and
so we're not buying enough insurance
against what scientists are telling us
is going to happen and it is happening
every day we're seeing return on a
prediction of 10 or 15 or 20 years ago
and it's frightening Lee coming back
faster and bigger than was predicted and
here's something that just infuriates me
and I'm sure everybody up here I know
Jerry shares this there is a report due
was due on August 18th mandated by
Congress special report and climate
science and that report has been sat on
prevented from being promulgated by
Scott Pruett at the EPA against the
rules and regulations just intervened
because that report has in it sentences
that talk about how there is increased
wind velocity cyclonic effect as a
result of warmer waters how there will
be increased floods it sorry they don't
want it they don't want the truth they
don't want the evidence and I just want
to emphasize what both Jay and Jerry
have said to you and I say this after 28
years the United States Senate and four
years as Secretary and I've run for
president and and at once and run for
Senate five times I believe in the power
that you have also and you have to
believe in it in 1970 when I came back
from Vietnam the first thing I did was
not protest the war the first thing I
did was work for Earth Day 1970 when 20
million Americans came out of their
homes and said we don't want to live
next to toxic waste sites we don't want
to live next to dumps that give you
cancer we do not want to watch rivers
like the Cuyahoga River light on fire we
want to do something about it and guess
what that 20 million people translated
subsequently into political action what
Jay was talking about Jerry so that we
targeted the 12 worst votes in the
United States Congress we labeled them
the Dirty Dozen and in the next election
seven of the twelve members of Congress
lost their seats let me tell you
something there is nothing like a bunch
of your friends
losing their seats to stiffen the spine
of elected officials what happened was
all of a sudden we passed Clean Air Act
Safe Drinking Water Act Marine Mammal
Protection Act Coastal Zone Management
Act we created the EPA and Richard Nixon
that brilliant environmentalists signed
that into law because it was a voting
issue now let me tell you I've had the
privilege of monitoring elections in a
lumber of countries over my career
beginning with the Philippines in 1986
with Cory Aquino and Ferdinand Marcos
and I have watched people in other
countries stand in the hot Sun at risk
sometimes of terrorism go out and vote
in 70 80 90 % numbers we were in the 50s
last year in this election
Jane Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton 50
percent that's just gross
it's unacceptable when I was here at
Yale as an undergraduate we almost had a
nuclear war the Missile Crisis with the
Soviet Union a president United States
was assassinated my sophomore year my
junior year we lined up buses on High
Street and sent people down south at
risk of life to help break the back of
segregation and senior year we
confronted the draft and the issue of
Vietnam and each of those years I saw us
empowered to make a difference no
campaign in America works without young
people we call them the peanut butter
and jelly Brigade being willing to come
into a campaign and slave at you know
horrible hours to help make a difference
so yes you've got to study
yes it's competitive as hell yes you've
got a career track but nobody has to be
in such a hurry that they can't take
time to be a good citizen and to be
involved in holding the Pruitts of this
world and everybody else accountable to
the law and to a vision which makes a
difference for our country and I hope
every single one of you and I know every
one of our
Eric hopes every single one of you will
do that please join me in thanking these
terrific leaders for the example they
are serving and being with us today
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you